meine damen und herren wir gehen wieder
zurück in den bundestag das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat den
bundestag beauftragt über die
sterbehilfe zu reden wie sie denn
weiterhin geregelt werden soll und ich
gebe damit ab an unsere reporterin im
bundestag katharina kühn
nicht richtig halten ja und hier hat die
debatte vor ein paar momenten schon
begonnen wir haben jetzt gleich rein
momentan am podium ist der herr gelind
der hier auch einen vorschlag
eingereicht hat unter anderem fordert
dort eine gruppe von abgeordneten ein
netz von staatlichen anerkannte
beratungsstellen alles weitere dann noch
gleich versucht haben beim assistierten
suizid also eine unterstützung für
denjenigen der sterbens willig ist oder
noch ringt aber auch für diejenigen die
helfen wollen und denen das nicht
verunmöglicht werden darf ohne sie dazu
zu zwingen von dieser perspektive aus
wollen wir denken und nicht von der
perspektive fragt würde der sterbehilfe
vereine aus und nicht von der
perspektive einer sterbehilfe
infrastruktur aus denn machen wir uns
klar wenn wir von der perspektive
ausdenken
vergessen wie ja dass diese vereine und
diese situation letztlich nur entstanden
sind weil es keine andere möglichkeit
gegenwärtig gibt
rechtssicher und tatsächlich zu helfen
und dieser richtige einzig richtige weg
ist derjenige über das
vertrauensverhältnis des betroffenen
sterbewilligen und des arztes und ärztin
kein anderer
dabei immer als möglichkeit als recht
als freiheit des arztes unter ärzten zu
helfen nicht als zwang
daher legen wir auch entschieden wert
darauf zu sehen das in form einer
umfassenden beratung auch der einzelne
die einzelne entscheiden kann informiert
wird auch über die konsequenzen eines
möglichen
fehlschlagen nicht funktionieren so ist
es über die auswirkung auf die
angehörigen wirklich voll umfänglich
informiert nicht in richtung suizid
sondern ergebnis offen denn nur
informierte gut aufgeklärte beratende
individuen und personen können wirklich
autonom und frei entscheiden und das ist
was wir wollen und was wir unterstützen
wollen ja mit müssen und sogar ethisch
geboten sind dies zu tun in diesem sinne
auch kann eine solche form der assistenz
sogar suizid präventiv sein denn für
viele ist das wissen dass sie irgendwann
die möglichkeit haben unterstützt aus
dem leben zu scheiden wenn sie dieses
leben nicht mehr als erträglich achten
befreit sie
nimmt ihn manchmal auch ja nicht selten
die ärztin herr zu berichten einen
aktiven sterbewunsch und entlastet sie
ja bringt sie dazu jetzt gegenwärtig
noch aktiver um das leben zu kämpfen und
kämpfen zu wollen
insofern ist auch diese möglichkeit
präventiv daher bitten wir sie
unterstützen sie unseren gesetzesentwurf
wir wollen anwälte sein cool der
betroffenen sterbewilligen wie auch der
helfenden und auch das leben ist nicht
des abstrakten sondern ihres konkretes
aber wir wollen nicht richter seien über
den einzelnen und seiner autonomen
getroffene entscheidung
haye gelingt war das geordnete der spd
diese orientierung die debatte findet
jetzt statt ohne fraktionszwang können
sich hier die abgeordneten äußern
deswegen gibt es hier auch schon
er einige vorschläge die
fraktionsübergreifend vorgeschlagen
wurden hier gelingt hat ja auch einen
vorgeschlagen der bundestag hat schon
vor gut einem jahr über die sterbehilfe
diskutiert damals hat man keine einigung
finden können und dann kam halt die
bundestagswahlen deswegen gibt es jetzt
sozusagen in dieser legislaturperiode
wieder eine erste orientierung debatte
denn das ist
notwendig weil das
bundesverfassungsgericht im februar 2020
das verbot geschäftsmäßige sterbehilfe
so wie es bis dahin galt als
verfassungswidrig erklärt hat und
deswegen gibt es jetzt hier wieder diese
orientierungs debatte
bundestags-vizepräsidentin petra pau
erläutert hier noch die regeln dafür
wenn ich jetzt die überzogen gezeigt
dass kollegen lind dem nächsten redner
oder der nächsten rednerinnen der
spd-fraktion abziele die vielleicht eine
andere position vertritt dann wird es
nicht nur ungerecht sondern wurde es
auch schwierig diese debatte in der
entsprechenden auch verabredeten art und
weise und mit würde zu gestalten also
tun sie mir bitte den gefallen und
achten sie darauf dass sie die
vereinbarten redezeiten einhalten was
sie hat hier noch mal darauf hingewiesen
normalerweise wenn ein abgeordneter
einer fraktion überzieht dann wird
innerhalb dieser fraktion dann diese
redezeit einem anderen redner abgezogen
da aber eben wie ich gesagt habe hier
keinen fraktionszwang
herrscht sondern diakonen nach ihrem
gewissen hier sprechen ist das schwierig
das dann umzusetzen nächster redner ist
jetzt ansgar heveling cdu csu rationen
kollegen vor etwas über siebeneinhalb
jahren im november 2014 haben wir hier
im plenum schon einmal über suizid
assistenz und sterbebegleitung
debattiert der seinerzeitige
bundestagspräsident norbert lammert
sprach von dem vermutlich
anspruchsvollsten gesetzgebungs projekt
der damaligen wahlperiode argumente und
emotionen breiten aufeinander die wie
nur wenige andere als existenziell
bezeichnet werden können die intensive
diskussion und der anschließend
gefundene kompromiss führten zu einer
der viel gerühmten sternstunden des
parlaments nun befinden wir uns nach
siebeneinhalb jahren wieder hier im
plenarsaal des bundestages und wieder
debattieren wir über suizid assistenz
aber wie heißt es bereits bei heraklit
man kann nicht zweimal in denselben
fluss steigen auch wenn wir heute wieder
über die suizid assistenz sprechen
führen wir nicht die diskussion des
jahres 2014 fort sondern sind mit der
entscheidung des zweiten senats des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
aus 2020 in einer neuen situation dort
hat das gericht ein recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben als ausdruck
persönlicher autonomie anerkannt und
dieses recht so das
bundesverfassungsgericht umfasst auch
die freiheit hierfür bei dritten hilfe
zu suchen und hilfe soweit sie angeboten
wird in anspruch zu nehmen aber schon
dieser verfassungsrechtlich eindeutige
ausgangspunkt wirft in der praxis
komplexe fragen auf wann ist der wunsch
dem eigenen leben ein ende zu setzen
ausdruck persönlicher autonomie wie soll
man herausfinden ob die entscheidung
eines sterbewilligen vielleicht gar
nicht selbst gesetzten gründen
entspringt sondern er sich sozialen
druck ausgesetzt sieht oder an einer
krankheit leidet die es ihm unmöglich
macht sein wunsch zu sterben und
selbstbestimmt zu reflektieren diese
situation voneinander abzugrenzen ist
keineswegs trivial denn das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat auch
unmissverständlich zum ausdruck gebracht
dass der staat dafür sorge zu tragen hat
dass der entschluss begleiteten suizid
zu begehen
tatsächlich aufheim willen beruht
angesichts der unumkehrbarkeit des
vollzugs einer suizid entscheidung so
das bundesverfassungsgericht
gebiete die bedeutung des lebens als ein
höchstwert innerhalb der
grundgesetzlichen ordnung selbsttötungen
entgegenzuwirken die nicht von freier
selbstbestimmung und eigenverantwortung
getragen sein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen hier
liegt die zentrale aufgabe jeder
zukünftigen regelungen die den
verfassungsrecht gerichtlichen vorgaben
gerecht werden will die autonomie des
einzelnen
autonomie des einzelnen und seine daraus
resultieren das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben müssen ebenso
geschützt werden wie das leben das ist
kein paradox sondern zeigt das leben und
sterben nicht losgelöst voneinander
betrachtet werden können über seinen tod
frei entscheiden kann nur wer lebt wer
einmal die grenze zum tod überschritten
hat kann seine entscheidung nicht
revidieren deshalb ist es so wichtig
dass sich der staat schützend vor das
leben des einzelnen stellt weil nur so
auch die autonomie des einzelnen
geschützt werden kann
ein
effektiver schutz der verantwortlichkeit
der entscheidung zur selbsttötung
verlangt die geschäftsmäßige förderung
der selbsttötung grundsätzlich unter
strafe zu stellen dabei geht es nicht um
die suizid assistenz als solche sondern
gegen die förderung von
geschäftsmodellen die dazu führen dass
die selbsttötung als normalfall der
lebens beendigung gehandelt wird es ist
bekannt dass in ländern in denen die
geschäftsmäßige suizid assistenz
weitgehend schrankenlos angeboten wird
die selbsttötung daten ausgesprochen
hoch sind wichtig ist es vielmehr im
rahmen eines klaren schutz konzeptes
ausnahmen für menschen zu schaffen die
frei und ernsthaft den entschluss
gefasst haben aus dem leben scheiden zu
wollen dazu bedarf es erstens der
feststellung der frei verantwortlichkeit
der entscheidung zur selbsttötung durch
fachärzte für psychiatrie und eine
umfassende
ergebnisoffene beratung als zweites in
sondersituationen etwa bei einer
fortgeschrittenen unheilbaren
erkrankungen bei einer zugleich
begrenzten lebenserwartung kann die
feststellung schneller getroffen werden
nur so durch eine strafrechtliche
regelung und ein schutzkonzept als
ausnahme schützen wir wirksam die
selbstbestimmung und deswegen vielen
dank
ansgar heveling war dass auch er hat
sich an einem vorschlag beteiligt in dem
unter anderem gefordert wird dass die
geschäftsmäßige förderung der
selbsttötung grundsätzlich strafbar
bleibt aber unter gewissen umständen
nicht strafrechtlich verfolgt wird und
kirsten kaputt gonther hat sich auch
diesem vorschlag angeschlossen
wenn wir über assistierten suizid reden
geht es im wahrsten sinne um leben und
tod und diese orientierungs debatte die
gibt uns die gelegenheit
argumente noch einmal abzuwägen und
eigene gewissheiten zu überprüfen
suizidalität ist häufig
in der regel haben menschen im laufe
ihres lebens auch mal suizidale gedanken
und darum ist es so wichtig dass wir das
tabu brechen und suizidalität
entstigmatisieren es fördert nämlich
nicht etwa suizidalität darüber zu reden
sondern es hilft dabei andere wege zu
finden
[Musik]
und die vorstellung
die häufig mal auch als argument
angeführt wird die vorstellung dass mit
der förderung des assistierten suizid
die sogenannten harten reduzierte also
die ziele reduziert würden die es leider
ein trugschluss
suizidalität entsteht immer im kontext
der lebenssituation suizid wünsche sind
in der regel nicht der wunsch nach dem
tod sondern der wunsch nach einer pause
von einer als unerträglich empfundenen
lebenssituation
über mehr als zwei jahrzehnte habe ich
als fachärztin für psychiatrie und
psychotherapie viele menschen in
suizidalen krisen begleitet und ich
finde es ist entscheidend dass wir hier
die prävention an erste stelle setzen
und dafür
hat eine gruppe der ich auch angehöre
bereits einen vorschlag gemacht einen
antrag zur stärkung durch suizid
prävention und wir legen zudem mit
dieser interfraktionellen gruppe von
abgeordneten aller demokratischen
fraktionen ein gesetzentwurf zur
regulierung der suizidbeihilfe vor der
das angebot von assistierten suizid den
zugang unter klare regeln stellt eine
gesellschaft in der schwierig ist an
gute pflege an krisenhilfe an eine
psychotherapie platz zu kommen aber es
womöglich an jeder ecke oder auch in
jedem pflegeheim eine umfasst
infrastruktur für den assistierten
suizid gebe dass wir für mich ein horror
szenario
wir dürfen doch menschen in not mit
ihrem problem nicht alleine lassen
stattdessen muss es buchstäblich an
jeder brücke hinweise für eine jederzeit
erreichbare suizid hotline geben
auch online auf anonym und das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns nun
aufgetragen die suizid assistenz zu
regeln mein kollege heveling ist schon
darauf eingegangen und der
regelungsbedarf ist virulent denn
zurzeit findet suizid assistenz statt
aber ohne eine gesetzliche rahmen das
gericht hat auch klargestellt dass
besonders gefahr trächtige angebote der
suizidbeihilfe verboten werden können
und dass ein schutzkonzept sinnvoll ist
gerade um die autonomie
abzusichern
meine gruppe setzt sich für eine
verankerung im strafrecht ein um eine
möglichst widerspruchsfreie gesetzgebung
umzusetzen der suizid assistenz anbietet
zum beispiel sterbehilfe vereine muss
sich an einen mehr augen prinzip und
wartefristen halten andernfalls macht er
sich strafbar und es wäre der tragweite
der entscheidung keinesfalls angemessen
wenn ein beamter am schreibtisch in der
arzneimittelbehörde mit einem stempel
ein suizid quasi staatlich absegnet im
gegenteil wer suizid assistenz anbietet
muss sicherstellen dass der suizid
wunsch freiverantwortlich entstanden ist
denn darum geht es liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen um selbstbestimmung und warum
nun setzt autonomie und selbstbestimmung
ein gutes schutzkonzept voraus das
klingt ja für einige vielleicht erst mal
kontra intuitiv eine selbstbestimmte
entscheidung setzt voraus dass diese
frei von inneren und äußeren
drucksituationen getroffen wurde
selbstbestimmung bedeutet eben die wahl
zu haben die selbstbestimmung aber ist
gefährdet wo der suizid wunsch durch
drucksituationen wie seelische krisen
armut aber auch das gefühl anderen zur
last zu fallen oder sich überflüssig zu
fühlen entsteht es braucht also
sinnvolle prozedurale regelung gerade um
die autonomie sicherzustellen und für
kinder
davon bin ich fest überzeugt sollte der
suizid der assistierte suizid klipp und
klar ausgeschlossen deren den
sterbehilfe
denn sterbe wünsche sind eben volatil
und das gilt ganz besonders für kinder
und jugendliche wir in unserer gruppe
sagen regeln wer den assistierten suizid
aber fördern ihn nicht stellen wir
sicher dass die autonomie gewahrt wird
und flankieren wir eine gesetzliche
regelung zum assistierten suizid mit
einer guten suizidprävention danke sehr
die ersten kapitel konter war das
mitglied der grünen in einem vorschlag
dem sich die nächste rednerin
angesprochen hat katrin helling klar
geht es im gegensatz zu dem vorschlag
von ihrer vorrednerin darum dass die
regelung zum suizid hilfe außerhalb des
strafrechts
formuliert wird
seit jahren streitet inzwischen
gemeinsam mit dr petra sitte mit helge
linz mit dr till steffen mit otto fricke
und vielen anderen gemeinsam für eine
liberale sterbehilfe regelung für die
menschen in unserem land seit jahren
erreichen mich tagtäglich nachrichten
von menschen die mir uns ihre
lebensumstände ihre schicksale schildern
die schmerzen haben die angst haben ich
kann es gut verstehen wenn man selbst
bestimmen möchte wann und wie das eigene
leben endet und ich kann gut verstehen
dass man emotional die sicherheit haben
möchte gehen zu dürfen wenn es für einen
selbst so weit ist
den menschen in ihren bedürfnissen zur
seite zu stehen ist meine motivation
ich streite für eine liberale
sterbehilfe regelung weil ich den
menschen die sicherheit geben möchte
dass sie ihr im grundgesetz verankertes
recht auf selbstbestimmtes sterben
ausüben können wenn sie es für geboten
halten deshalb ist es für mich
indiskutabel eine neue regelung der
sterbehilfe im strafrecht überhaupt nur
anzudenken ich finde wir sollten
denjenigen die bereit sind menschen auf
ihrem letzten weg zu begleiten ihn zu
helfen mit respekt begegnen statinen mit
strafe bedrohten
schaffen wir für die menschen
stattdessen mit einem liberalen
sterbehilfe gesetz recht klarheit ohne
uns noch einmal moralisch über sie zu
erheben das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
ganz klar gesagt einen gegen die
autonomie gerichteten lebensschutz kann
und darf es nicht die stehen wir
menschen die über einen suizid
nachdenken zur seite indem wir
flächendeckend und bundesweit
niederschwellige beratungsmöglichkeiten
schaffen etablieren wie echte
anlaufstellen und bieten wir dort auf
konkrete hilfe zum beispiel auf dem weg
ins pflegeheim an
seien sie schließlich aber auch so
ehrlich und eröffnen denjenigen die sich
entscheiden gehen zu wollen die
möglichkeit nach beratung und ärztlicher
verschreibung ein medikament wie natrium
pentobarbital das ja auch in der schweiz
anwendung findet zu erhalten denn ich
finde es gebietet die menschlichkeit
betroffene mit ihrem recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben nicht mehr
alleine zu lassen und sie nicht weiter
auf risikoreichere methoden gar oft
brutal suizide zu verweisen aber lassen
wir vertraute ärzte über verschreibung
entscheiden nicht anonyme behörden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen nicht mal bei
der entscheidung zu § 2 17
strafgesetzbuch in karlsruhe das urteil
das das bundesverfassungsgericht vor
inzwischen gut zwei jahren gesprochen
hat war unmissverständlich und ist
wegweisend ich möchte uns alle aufrufen
das urteil und seine erwägungen zu
achten das recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben braucht ausreichend raum es darf
nicht noch einmal wegen zu hoher
gesetzlicher würden faktisch leer laufen
das sind wir den menschen in unserem
land schuldig vielen dank
dass ein händler hat ja auch noch mal
das urteil aus karlsruhe erwähnt in dem
die richter unter anderem gesagt haben
dass das allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht
auch als ausdruck persönlichkeit
persönliche autonomie ein recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben umfasst thomas
seitz spricht jetzt die fraktion
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren die selbsttötung ist in
deutschland straflos bei kein fremdes
rechtsgut verletzt wird damit ist
grundsätzlich auch die förderung der
selbsttötung straflos im jahr 2015 wurde
deshalb mit dem verbot der
geschäftsmäßigen förderung der
selbsttötung eine beihilfe handlung zum
eigenständigen delikt erhoben seit 2020
das bundesverfassungsgericht diese
vorschrift für mit dem grundgesetz
unvereinbar erklärt hat geht es jenseits
des ärztlichen standesrecht es wieder an
einer regelung dies bedeutet
rechtsunsicherheit und die gefahr von
auswüchsen der gesetzgeber ist also
gefordert den assistierten suizid zu
regeln die vorgaben haben gesetzeskraft
und sind eindeutig zitat das recht auf
selbstbestimmte sterben erstreckt sich
auch auf die entscheidung des einzelnen
sein leben eigenhändig zu beenden und
weiter das recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben ist nicht auf fremd definierte
situationen wie schwere oder unheilbare
krankheitszustände beschränkt eine
einengung des schutzbereichs auf
bestimmte ursachen und motive liefe auf
eine bewertung der beweggründe zur
selbsttötung und auf eine inhaltliche
vorbestimmung hinaus die mit dem
freiheitsgedanken des grundgesetzes
fremd sind nach entscheidungen auf der
einzelne selbst entscheiden was sein
verständnis für lebensqualität und
sinnhaftigkeit seiner existenz ausmacht
staat und gesellschaft haben diese
entscheidung als akt autonome
selbstbestimmung zu respektieren mit
diesen vorgaben des
bundesverfassungsgerichts muss die zu
schaffende regelung einen zumutbaren weg
zu einem selbstbestimmten freitod
eröffnen was einen legalen zugang zum
betäubungsmittel natrium-pentobarbital
erfordert festzuhalten ist aber auch
dass kein arzt oder apotheker
verpflichtet ist an der selbsttötung
eines anderen mitzuwirken
gleichzeitig bietet die schutzpflicht
für das leben ein tragfähiges konzept
für ein freien suizid bedarf ist
zunächst der fähigkeit der freien
willensbildung und der fähigkeit auch
nach dieser einsicht zu handeln
die willensbildung muss frei von
beeinträchtigungen durch krankheit seien
vor allem durch akute psychische
störungen ein problem gerade bei
betagten und schwerkranken menschen die
oft unter suizidgedanken infolge einer
depression leiden weiter muss der
betroffene gut informiert sein um auf
einer soliden beurteilungsgrundlage das
für und wider realistisch abzuwenden
dazu gehört insbesondere dass er
handlungsalternativen zum suizid erkennt
ihre jeweiligen folgen bewertet und sich
in kenntnis aller erheblichen umstände
und optionen entscheidet
ebenso muss gewährleistet sein dass sich
der betroffene frei von zwang drohung
täuschung oder sonstigen formen der
beeinflussung für den suizid entscheidet
die regelung muss auch sicherstellen
dass der entschluss aus dem leben zu
scheiden von einer gewissen
dauerhaftigkeit und inneren festigkeit
getragen ist dann nach den gerichtlichen
vorgaben je nach lebenssituation
unterschiedliche anforderungen an den
nachweis der dauerhaftigkeit und
ernsthaftigkeit eines selbst
tötungswillen gestellt werden können
dafür differenziert werden zwischen
menschen mit schweren oder
fortgeschrittenen erkrankungen
einerseits und völlig gesunden menschen
andererseits alle diese voraussetzungen
sind selbstredend bei kindern und
jugendlichen nicht gegeben mit der
regelung des rieds ist es aber nicht
getan gegen niederschwelliger der zugang
zur palliativmedizin und hospizdiensten
ist umso eher ist der betroffene bereit
seine situation auch ohne suizid zu
ertragen und vor allem bedarf die
suizidprävention ganz allgemein einer
massiven förderung denn eines darf nicht
vergessen werden auch wenn der suizid
nicht strafbar ist so hat doch jeder
suizid schwere auswirkungen auf das
gesamte umfeld und ist immer auch eine
tragödie vielen dank
thomas seitz er war dass er jetzt auch
rechtspolitischer sprecher seiner
fraktion hat hier in der orientierungs
debatte zum
suizid zur sterbehilfe gesprochen auf
ihn folgt nun petra sitte angst der
linksfraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
sie steht nun im zentrum und am anfang
des grundgesetzes und aus ihr leitet
sich das selbstbestimmungsrecht des
einzelnen menschen ab und zur würde und
selbstbestimmung gehört das recht das
eigene leben zu beenden
diese entscheidung so das
bundesverfassungsgericht in seinem
urteil dem eigenen leben entsprechend
dem eigenen verständnis von
lebensqualität und sinnhaftigkeit der
eigenen existenz ein ende zu setzen
haben wir zu respektieren damit hat das
gericht vor allem die perspektive der
betroffenen aufgenommen es steht also so
mit niemandem zu zu bewerten aus welcher
lebenssituation heraus der wunsch auf
suizidhilfe entstanden ist und hier war
das bundesverfassungsgericht für viele
überraschend klar
würde und selbstbestimmung müssen
ansatzpunkt jeder gesetzlichen regelung
sein der selbstbestimmte tod ist in den
worten des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ein letzter
ausdruck von würde dies ist recht meine
damen und herren muss praktisch aber
auch wahrnehmbar sein daraus ergibt sich
auch dass die hilfe durch dritte
straffrei sein muss wir tragen hier
gemeinsam verantwortung dafür dass
betroffene die möglichkeit finden
umfassend zu den konsequenzen ihrer
entscheidung aufgeklärt und beraten zu
werden sowohl zu rechtlichen als eben
auch zu medizinischen fragen und
schließlich auch zu hilfsangeboten
und alternativen
diese beratung muss fachlich kompetent
sein sie darf keinen druck aufbauen
weder in die eine noch in die andere
richtung und
vor allem musik zugänglich für alle sein
was bedeutet vor diesem hintergrund soll
dann der zugang zu einem humanen vollzug
des suizids auch tatsächlich ermöglicht
werden denn ein recht das sich in der
praxis nicht ausüben lässt ist kein
recht meine damen und herren niemand
hier möchte dass suizidhilfe in einem
kommerziellen rahmen erfolgt aber
hilfe zur wahrnehmung eines rechts darf
nicht unter strafe gestellt werden es
geht schließlich um mehr fürsorge stadt
mehr strafrecht es geht um mehr schutz
statt bevormundung wir können
kommerziellen angeboten den boden
entziehen indem
beratungsangebote unentgeltlich
gestaltet werden und allen zugänglich
sind das heißt
das heißt statt sozialen und
ökonomischen druck soll auch in dieser
letzten phase des lebens solidarität und
achtung geboten werden danke
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin martina stamm
biebrich aus der spd fragt zu
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr verehrte
bürgerinnen und bürger wenn wir das
thema suizid wenn wir das thema
suizidhilfe sprechen dann tun wir das
oft mit einem ganz bestimmten bild vor
augen
wir stellen uns dann todkranke menschen
vor die durch unendliches leid und kaum
aus haltbare schmerzen schwer gezeichnet
sind
menschen die einfach nicht mehr
weiterleben wollen oder können
menschen die liebe ihr leben nur noch
als belastung und den eigenen tod als
erlösung empfunden
in seinem urteil zur suizidhilfe hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht die rechte
dieser menschen gestärkt
es hat klipp und klar deutlich gemacht
dass jeder mensch das recht auf
selbstbestimmte sterben hat das hat auch
dieses haus zu respektieren und deshalb
stehen und sitzen wir heute hier
gleichzeitig das gericht aber betont
dass ich das selbstbestimmungsrecht über
das eigene leben eben gerade nicht auf
unheilbare krankheitszustände wo der
bestimmte lebens und krankheitsphasen
beschränkt nein es gilt für uns alle
egal ob alt oder jung krank oder gesund
das beispiel des unheilbar kranken ist
deshalb nur ein kleiner ausschnitt der
realität mit der wir jetzt umgehen
müssen diese realität kennt keine
vorgefertigten schablonen und diese
realität umfasst menschen die aus den
verschiedensten persönlichen gründen
ihrem leben ein ende setzen wollen
es ist nicht unsere aufgabe
werturteile darüber zu fällen weshalb
jemand sein leben beenden möchte es ist
auch nicht die aufgabe dieses hauses
festzulegen wann es akzeptabel ist wenn
jemand sich das leben nehmen möchte
ich warne deshalb entschieden davor dass
ich dieses haus eine bewertung der
individuellen gründe für diese
entscheidung an mast und so bestimmten
menschen ihre rechte vorenthält
wichtig vor allem ist aber folgende wir
müssen vorsorge dafür treffen dass die
frei verantwortlichkeit und die
dauerhaftigkeit des sterbewunsch es zu
jeder zeit sichergestellt ist
menschen die sich den tod wünschen
müssen besonders gut vor zwang und
manipulation geschützt werden
es liegt in unserer verantwortung
einen rechtssicheren rahmen hierfür zu
schaffen wir müssen uns durch
entsprechende schutzbestimmungen
verhindern dass die frei
verantwortlichkeit der entscheidung
durch psychischen
gesellschaftlichen oder wirtschaftlichen
druck in frage gestellt wird
gleichzeitig
müssen wir aber auch sicherstellen dass
das recht auf selbstbestimmte sterben
nicht durch blockieren das
verwaltungshandeln eingeschränkt wird es
braucht also einen geregelten prozess
der den menschen die wahrnehmung ihres
rechtes erlaubt diejenigen einrichtungen
in denen künftig suizidhilfe geleistet
werden wird brauchen wir von uns hier
die entsprechende unterstützung um diese
neue herausforderung gut zu bewältigen
das sind unsere aufgaben nicht mehr und
nicht weniger
klar ist für mich auch dass es dort wo
die frei verantwortlichkeit regelhaft
nicht gewährleistet dass etwa bei
kindern oder bei menschen mit
rechtlicher betreuung keine suizidhilfe
geben darf
genauso wenig kommt die suizidhilfe
patientenverfügungen frage weil die kuh
die novität der sterbewunsch ist so
nicht sichergestellt werden kann
ich will am ende meiner rede noch zwei
ganz wichtige punkte ansprechen die wir
im rahmen dieses verfahrens ebenfalls
unbedingt adressieren sollten kollegin
kabarett sondern hat schon getan zum
einen geht es um die stärkung der
suizidprävention und zum anderen um die
stärkung der palliativmedizinischen
versorgung
eine neue regelung der suizidhilfe
sollte beide punkte mit aufnehmen und
von vornherein die zahl der
suizidwilligen personen zu senken ich
weiß dass viele kolleginnen und kollegen
das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes sehr kritisch
sehen dennoch rufe ich sie heute dazu
auf begreifen wir dieses urteil als
chance begreifen wir dieses urteil als
chance dafür einen rahmen zu schaffen
dass er menschen mit frei
verantwortlichen und dauerhaften stabel
wunsch ermöglicht mit würde aus dem
leben zu scheiden vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
der bundestag diskutiert über die
sterbehilfe es gibt schon drei
gesetzentwürfe die werden hier aber noch
nicht beraten sondern nach dieser
orientierungs debatte wird an diesen
entwürfen weitergearbeitet ehesten kann
auch noch neue kommen und dann soll im
sommer eine erste lesung im parlament
abgehalten werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
urteil des bundesverfassungsgericht hat
uns einen auftrag gegeben die frage nach
den gesetzlichen regelungen zur
sterbehilfe hier im deutschen bundestag
zu diskutieren diese grundfrage des
menschlichen daseins berührt mehr als
jede andere die identität und die
individualität in dieser orientierungs
debatte gibt es kein richtig und es gibt
kein falsch es gibt kein schwarz es gibt
kein weiß es gibt kein oben es gibt kein
unten das heißt aber nicht dass diese
entscheidung keine auswirkungen hat
unser grundgesetz baut auf die würde des
schon auf die in unserem christlichen
menschenbild fest verankert ist dazu
gehört auch dass die freie entscheidung
für selbstbestimmtes sterben von
einzigen von jedem einzelnen getroffen
werden kann bei den gesetzlichen
regelungen kann es aber nicht alleine um
die entscheidung des einzelnen gehen der
gesellschaftliche und der kulturelle
umgang mit dem tod ist prägend für eine
soziale gemeinschaft sterben und tod
sind nicht nur eine privatangelegenheit
sie berühren auch die gesellschaft als
ganzes richtig ist weil dieser debatte
geht es um die zentrale ethischen fragen
für unsere gesellschaft über den umgang
mit dem leben und dem tod daher müssen
wir als gesellschaft die notwendigen
ethischen leitplanken diskutieren und
setzen papst johannes paul der zweite
hat einmal gesagt ich zitiere der tod
zwingt den menschen sich die radikalen
fragen nach dem eigentlichen sinn des
lebens zu stellen
das habe ich ganz persönlich erlebt als
mein vater im jahr 2004 als ich 25 jahre
alt war unheilbar krank an darmkrebs
erkrankt ist und zwei jahre später an
den lebermetastasen verstorben ist
zeitweise waren die schmerzen für ihn
fast nicht zu ertragen vielleicht hat er
sich auch manchmal gedacht es wäre
besser wenn er seinem leben und dem leid
ein ende setzen würde vielleicht hat er
sich gedacht er könnte seiner familie so
das miterleben des leides ersparen aber
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
er hat es nicht getan und er hat mir
etwas wichtiges mitgegeben es gibt nicht
nur schatten und licht nur leid und
glückseligkeit das leben ist viel
facettenreicher
nach der ambulanten chemotherapie gegen
mein vater in die kirche in meiner
heimatstadt in böblingen hat eine kerze
angezündet ging danach in die kneipen
hatten bier getrunken das hat mir
gezeigt er war geprägt vom leid aber er
hat trotzdem noch so viel leben in sich
viele erfahrungen die er mir und meiner
familie damit mitgeben mit gegeben hat
hat mich sehr stark und tief geprägt
unser entwurf den wir heute hier
diskutieren möchte diese freie
entscheidungen über das leben und
sterben schützen der staat muss
sicherstellen dass diese umkehrbare
entscheidung unumkehrbare entscheidung
frei und ohne jeden druck getroffen wird
wir brauchen in deutschland daher einen
klar definierten gesetzlichen rahmen
nicht für das selbstbestimmte sterben
sondern zum schutz der selbstständigen
entscheidung über das eigene leben
alte und kranke menschen dürfen nicht
das gefühl haben dass druck auf sie
ausgeübt wird dies zu verhindern ist die
oberste pflicht des staates er schützt
damit das recht auf ein selbstbestimmtes
und würdevolles leben ich bin davon
überzeugt dass es richtig ist so paradox
es auch klingen mag dass bei der frage
des selbstbestimmten scherben zimmer den
schutz des lebens und die würde des
menschen in den mittelpunkt zu stellen
ist das haben wir in unserem
gruppenantrag getan der assistierten
selbstmord darf niemals die normale form
der lebens beendigung werden
insbesondere für alte und kranke
menschen wir haben daher in unserem
gesetzentwurf klar eine regelung im
strafgesetzbuch
vorgesehen die die geschäftsmäßige
förderung von selbsttötung strafbar
lässt den menschen soll nach unserem
entwurf weit reichende hilfsangebote
gemacht werden und werbung für
attestierten selbstmord soll
strafrechtlich verboten werden ich weiß
darüber kann man viel diskutieren und
dafür kann man auch viel hier in diesem
hohen haus streiten aber mir geht es
darum gute rahmenbedingungen eben auch
mit einem und diesem uns vorgesetzten
gesetzentwurf den wir oder den ich hier
mit vertreten möchte deswegen meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen der
mensch steht im mittelpunkt bei dieser
frage und daher würde ich mich freuen
wenn sie unseren gesetzentwurf
unterstützen würden dankeschön
so
markiert dass aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
bei den gesetzentwürfen handelt es sich
allerdings über
fraktionsübergreifende initiative
renate künast spricht als nächstes die
grünen-fraktion
haupt präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
im kern geht es um selbstbestimmung das
ist das was das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes uns
mitgegeben haben das hat im 420
klargestellt dass aus dem allgemeinen
persönlichkeitsrecht
quasi als ausdruck persönlicher
autonomie das recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben volk und deshalb auch das recht
sich dazu einer hilfe zu bedienen und
deshalb hatten sie den damaligen
paragraf 217 für nichtig erklärt den wir
hier auch intensiv diskutiert haben
tatsache ist heute und das sage ich weil
einige gesagt haben das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns einen
auftrag gegeben hat es nicht wir könnten
die situation jetzt einfach so lassen
als bundestag
der 217 ist wichtig andere dinge sind
geregelt tötung auf verlangen ist
strafbar nein meine damen und herren die
frage ist ob wir das wollen ob wir als
bundestag und mühen wollen dazu einen
rahmen zu setzen
schutzregeln 1 zu sein tatsache ist nach
dieser entscheidung findet beihilfe zur
sterbehilfe stadt vereine beraten
ärztinnen und ärzten machen beihilfe
fragen sich wir fragen uns aber an
dieser stelle gibt es eigentlich die
notwendige transparenz welche mittel
verschreiben die da eigentlich meine
damen und herren und das ist für uns für
die gruppe um milch katja keul am franke
frauscher frau bayram herr bender und
andere ist für uns der punkt zu sagen
wir brauchen eine rechts einheitliche
regelung die im ganzen bundesgebiet geht
wir brauchen
schutzmechanismen an der stad beratung
zuverlässigkeitsprüfung und eine
transparenz und deshalb sagen wir nein
wir können jetzt nicht sagen geregelt es
nicht wir brauchen eine regelung es ist
aufgabe und wir dürfen uns nicht dafür
drücken und das bundesverfassungsgericht
hat ja übrigens auch immer klar gesagt
man darf nicht verhindern dass es ein
weg gibt in zumutbarer weise sein leben
zu beenden und deshalb meine damen und
herren geht es hier um die eine frage
kriegt man gute beratung durch vereine
nicht irgendwelche sondern auch
zuverlässige hat man den zugang zu
betäubungsmittel zum beispiel zu
pentobarbital bei dem auch
palliativmedizinern mediziner sagen das
ist dann eigentlich der zumutbare und
geeignete weg stein zu haben bei dem sie
möglicherweise reflexartig sich noch
erbrechen obwohl sich sterben wollen und
am ende mit schweren behinderungen da
liegen meine damen und herren das ist
nicht würdevoll und wir alle haben eins
die aufgabe es bleibt uns gar nichts
anderes übrig als die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgericht zu respektieren
jeder mensch hat das recht in jeder
lebensphase wir meinen wenn man jetzt an
die frage geht die regelt man dass man
sollte es jetzt nicht zu schwer machen
deshalb kritisch auf den blick mit einer
strafvorschrift zu beginn die als erstes
sagt drei jahre freiheitsstrafe wir
meinen aber auch man sollte es nicht zu
leicht machen war die manchen bereichen
vielleicht können wir auch nicht alles
millimetergenau regeln diebe kolleginnen
und klingen in manchen bereichen ist
schwierig wir haben zum beispiel gesagt
volljährige sollen den zugang haben
warum den diskutieren gerne im ausschuss
dann noch drüber aber ab welchem alter
ist jemand in der pubertät trotzdem vom
freiem willen beseelt und kann danach
handeln was ist mit der entscheidung der
eltern oder familiengericht wie stehen
die drei zu einander
schwierig meine damen und herren aber
auf alle fälle nicht zu schwer bestraft
gesetzt wird sich nicht zu einfach
machen meine damen und herren und
natürlich wir haben nicht das recht
materielle kriterien aufzustellen wir
können verfahrensvorschriften machen und
sagen wir müssen sehen dass es
freiwillig ist ein freier wille und die
fähigkeit danach zu handeln und dann
müssen wir dem weg zumutbar eröffnete
meine damen und herren und dieser weg
muss heißen schutzvorschriften
transparenzvorschriften zuverlässigkeit
in dem verein beratungs
beratungsfristen zwischen zwei beratung
meine damen und herren und aufklärung
über wirkungsweisen das ethische dach
für uns ist wir haben zehn fahrer vier
unseres gesetzesentwurfes formuliert
nämlich ausdrücklich der grundwert jedes
menschenlebens das ist sozusagen der
ethische punkt und ich will einmal an
dieser stelle konkret wäre wie wir es
regeln möchten meine damen und herren
wir haben uns gesagt für volljährige
habe ich gesagt und wir machen jetzt
zwei wege unser vorschlag ist zwei wege
zu machen die wir für adäquate am weg 1
ist die voraussetzung für den zugang zu
und betäubungsmittel für sterbewillige
in medizinische notlage wir stellen uns
vor dass jemand in existenzieller not
luftnot ist den kann ich nicht noch
irgendwohin schicken sondern für den die
person ermöglichen wir und wollen wir
ermöglichen den weg an der stelle mit
dem behandelten ärztin oder arzt das
gespräch zu führen mit regeln wie das
schriftlich darzulegen ist mit
aufklärungs dokumentationspflichten mit
einem zweiten arzt oder einer ärztin die
unabhängig davon sagen sagen muss dass
dieser freie wille vorliegt und
aufgeklärt wurde meine damen und herren
ich glaube dass es angemessen ist zumal
in diesem punkt wir beides haben nämlich
auch die beratung vielleicht aber eine
schmerztherapie und der andere weg meine
damen und herren ist bei uns der zugang
für in allen anderen fällen wo wir sagen
es muss eine behörde geben der gegenüber
meint man seinen sterbewunsch glaubhaft
darlegt die dauer darlegt und ein zwei
fragen beantwortet das fazit meine damen
und herren ist wir wissen wir müssen
nicht wir können regeln einen schutz
vorschrift machen dann sollten wir sie
auch tun und
für meine begriffe ist es so dass wir
den weg gehen sollten dass sie einen die
ärzte des vertrauens kontaktieren können
die anderen einen offenen zugang haben
und neben allen meine damen und herren
würde ich sagen was wir wirklich
sträflich vernachlässigt haben ist die
gesamte bereich der flächendeckenden
guten versorgung am palliativ und
hospizversorgung
gelegenheit auch verändern
sagt renate künast nächster redner ist
benjamin strasser ist zwar
parlamentarischer staatssekretär beim
justizministerium
allerdings entspricht der hier heute
nicht in dieser funktion sondern wie die
anderen auch als abgeordneter auch er
hat sich an einem gesetzentwurf
beteiligt
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat mit seinem
urteil aus dem februar 2020 für klarheit
gesorgt klar ist dass eine jahrelange
debatte und das ob des assistierten
suizids beendet ist wir diskutieren
jetzt über das wie klar ist auch dass
das urteil einen regelungs losen zustand
hinterlassen hat mit dem viele abgesehen
von manchen sterbehilfen verein
unzufrieden sind und ja das ist eine
schwierige aufgabe für uns als
gesetzgeber das ist sicher keiner leicht
macht für mich ist aber auch klar nichts
tun kann keine option sein liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat aber auch
den rahmen des diskurses verschoben in
cannes steht jetzt die frage wie sichern
wir tatsächlich
selbstbestimmung für alle menschen in
allen lebenslagen es geht eben nicht
mehr nur um schwerstkranke menschen in
der letzten phase ihres lebens es geht
auch um menschen mit einer
suchterkrankung psychischen erkrankungen
es geht um menschen mit behinderungen es
geht um menschen die in armut leben und
ja es geht auch um menschen die
pflegebedürftig werden und die sich die
frage stellen investiere ich mein geld
und teile meines geldes in einem
pflegeplatz oder gebe ich es meinen
kindern und enkelkindern und gerade
dieses beispiel ist nicht konstruiert
sondern die ängste die befürchtungen sie
sind messbar so wollen laut einer studie
mit dem titel 55plus pflege im alter
74 der bürgerinnen und bürger bei einem
pflegefall ihren kindern nicht zur last
fallen und die gespräche die wir in den
letzten zwei jahren geführt haben mit
ärztinnen und ärzten mit sterne
begleiterinnen und begleiter die decken
sich mit dieser studienlage und deswegen
müssen wir auch anerkennen dass
nicht jeder sterbewunsch ein suizid
wunsch ist die äußerung von betroffenen
ich will nicht mehr leben ist wenn man
sich mit diesem wunsch auseinander satz
wird mit ihnen spricht oftmals eben
eigentlich als ich will so nicht um ihr
leben gemacht und deswegen wenn ihr
selbstbestimmung ernst gehen dann müssen
wir diese schwierige entscheidung
absichern wir müssen sie ab sicherlich
eine umfassende beratung über die
alternativen des assistierten suizid wir
müssen sie absichern dadurch dass die
alternativen zum suizid tatsächlich auch
zeitnah verfügbar sind und ja wir müssen
sie auch absichern dadurch dass eine
unzulässige beeinflussung durch tritte
in dieser heiklen phase bestmöglich
ausgeschlossen ist und dazu hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht uns eben auch
den weg weiteren offen gelassene
generalpräventiven wirkung das
strafrecht es geht hier nicht um
bevormundung es geht nicht um
kriminalisierung sondern es geht darum
dass das schutzkonzept über die
selbstbestimmung nicht nur im
bundesgesetzblatt steht sondern der
praxis tatsächlich geliebt
soweit die rede von benjamin strasser
hier in dieser orientierungs debatte
nächster redner ist martin sicherheit im
ersten aus gesundheitspolitischer
sprecher der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
in den letzten zwei jahren würde bei
nahezu jeder gesundheitspolitischen
debatte so getan als gelte es jedes
leben um jeden preis zu erhalten und
heute nun diskutieren wir darüber wie
der staat menschen dabei helfen sollte
ihr leben zu beenden
obwohl es 2020 eine deutliche
unterschiedlichkeit gehabt wurden
millionen psychisch kranke zehntausende
krebskranke und zehntausende mit
schweren nebenwirkungen in kauf genommen
um zu versuchen zu verhindern dass auch
nur ein weiterer mensch als corona tote
meer stirbt nun also diskutieren wir
hier über sterbehilfe und ich fand es
sehr interessant zu beobachten dass
einige der befürworter schärfster corona
maßnahmen mit all den damit verbundenen
gesundheitsschäden sich nun für
weitreichende sterbehilfe aussprechen
zwei jahre wurden würde und
selbstbestimmung mit füßen getreten ist
freut mich sehr dass hier und heute nun
viele würde und selbstbestimmung in den
vordergrund stellen und ich wünsche mir
dass das künftig auch bei allen anderen
themen so sein wird
es muss klar sein dass sterbehilfe
anders als corona nicht zum
geschäftsmodell mit milliardengewinnen
für pharma- und ärzte werden darf es
muss sichergestellt werden dass niemand
besser verdient wenn sich am ende einer
beratung jemand für den tod entscheidet
als wenn derjenige sich für das leben
entscheidet und die entscheidung über
sterbehilfe sollte nur derjenige selbst
treffen können aber man sollte eine
möglichkeit einräumen durch die der
mensch in einer patientenverfügung
bestimmte parameter festlegen kann wann
er sterbehilfe in anspruch nehmen möchte
wenn jemand bei vollem bewusstsein eine
verfügung formuliert dass er wenn er
massive schmerzen hat und beispielsweise
nach einem schlaganfall nicht mehr
seinen willen klar formulieren kann der
sterbehilfe in anspruch nehmen möchte
warum sollte man es ihm verwehren
grundsätzlich sollte sterbehilfe aber
eng begrenzt sein wer unheilbar krank
ist der starke schmerzen hat und leidet
der sollte das recht haben sein leiden
zu beenden und dabei auch unterstützung
finden das ist menschlich bei schweren
leiden muss das auch ohne lange
wartezeiten möglich seien auch bei
menschen bei denen man weiß dass die
beendigung lebenserhaltender maßnahmen
mit leid verbunden sind weil die
menschen schmerzen haben oder das
sterben sich tage lang hinzieht bis der
mensch elendig erstickt oder verdurstet
ist sollte es die möglichkeit geben mit
der spritze dem leid ein schnelles ende
zu setzen aber gesunden menschen dabei
zu helfen sich aus dem leben zu
befördern nur weil diese lebensmüde sind
das ist nicht aufgabe des staates das
hat auch der europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte in seinem urteil vom
zwölften april dieses jahres
festgestellt in dem erklärt wurde dass
es kein grundsätzliches recht auf
beihilfe zum suizid gibt und das sollten
wir alle auch bedenken wenn wir uns um
die entsprechenden anträge vielen dank
vielen dank
[Applaus]
martin sichert war dass ich habe eben
schon gesagt sprecher für
gesundheitspolitik und auch die nächste
rednerin hat diese funktion inne kathrin
vogler für die linksfraktion
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich bin sehr froh zu hören ist zumindest
in den demokratischen parteien noch
einen konsens gibt dass es grenzen gibt
dass es zum beispiel die tötung auf
verlangen in keinem der bisher
vorliegenden gesetzentwürfe legalisiert
werden soll denn ich finde wir müssen
darauf achten gerade wenn wir über
dieses sensible thema reden dass wir
grenzen waren und dass wir auch nicht
unterscheiden zwischen menschen die
krank sind die psychisch krank sind die
behindert sind oder menschen die gesund
sind das erweckt doch das würde doch
erwecken ganz schlimme erinnerungen an
die geschichte dieses landes und auch da
bin ich froh dass wir uns sehr breit
hier in diesem hause auf der
demokratischen seite einig sind wir
werden heute darüber wie wir verhindern
können dass menschen die sich
entschieden haben ihr leben zu beenden
und durch ein angeboten angebots
getriebenes marktsystem dazu gedrängt
werden könnten und wie sie angemessen
unterstützung und beratung und damit
einen weg aus ihrer lebenskrise finden
können und wenn wir darüber sprechen
dann müssen wir uns auch über die
realität der mangelhaften
suizidprävention in diesem land
unterhalten in dem sich jeden tag etwa
25 menschen das leben nehmen und deshalb
schlägt die gruppe der die ich
unterstütze mit frau kaputt konter und
herrn castellucci herrn heveling und
anderen auch vor dass wir ein gesetz zur
suizidprävention
schaffen das fordern auch viele verbände
und institutionen die menschen mit
psychischen erkrankungen mit
behinderungen oder pflegebedarf
vertreten und die sich mit den sozialen
nöten von menschen in zeiten immer
ungleiche lebensverhältnisse und
zunehmender existenzsorgen beschäftigen
und ich lade sie ein beteiligen sie sich
darin lassen sie egal welchen
gesetzentwurfs sie bevorzugen dieses
thema in den mittelpunkt stellen und
mehr tun für suizidprävention in diesem
land
auch lars castellucci der nächste redner
hat sich hier mit einem vorschlag
beteiligt im vorfeld hat er auch schon
gesagt er wolle den assistierten suizid
ermöglichen aber nicht fördern und
herren
warum ist der suizid oder der
assistierte suizid
eigentlich die klare ausnahme in unserer
gesellschaft hat das etwas mit tradition
zu tun oder mit tabus oder mit
mangelndem zugang
ich glaube ganz entscheidend für die
allermeisten menschen ist ihr
lebenswille
lebenswille gerade wenn es auf das
sterben zugeht hoffnung es könnte noch
rettung geben noch erleben dass der
enkel zur welt kommt und deshalb ja ich
bin der meinung das wird den sterbe
willen und in dieser konsequenz auch den
suizid willen von menschen anerkennen
müssen aber viel mehr bin ich der
meinung dass wir ihren lebenswillen
unterstützen müssen so lange und mit
allem was uns möglich ist
es kann ihnen von leben immer wieder
situationen geben in denen unser
lebenswille wie verschüttet ist krisen
gesundheitlich zeiten der trauer
depressive phasen und dann können auch
suizid gedanken kommen und sie sind und
es hat kerstin körperkontakt gesagt
ebenso wenn der mainstraße sie sind eben
in den allermeisten fällen nicht mit
einem sterbewunsch verbunden sondern mit
dem bund nicht so leben zu müssen wer
sich aktuell darstellt wir geben viel
geld für forschung aus in diesem bereich
die ergebnisse dieser forschung sind
eindeutig wir sollten sie es in diesem
gesetzgebungsverfahren
berücksichtigen
und deswegen ist unsere debatte
korrekter weise auch suizidhilfe heißen
und nicht sterbehilfe denn ein suizid
wurde ist eben nicht automatisch mit
einem sterbewunsch gleichzusetzen
also geht es in den allermeisten fällen
auch nicht vorschnell darum
möglichkeiten des sterbens aufzuzeigen
sondern hilfe und unterstützung im leben
anzubieten und ich will dass diese hilfe
und unterstützung zum und im leben auch
künftig die chance haben die menschen
eher zu erreichen als organisationen die
sich vielleicht eine schwäche eine
momentane schwäche eines menschen
zunutze machen und einen weg zum
schnellen tod versprechen wie wir das
sicher stellen darum geht es in den
kommenden beratungen und eines ist für
mich klar frau helling klar mit
flächendeckenden staatlich finanzierten
suizid beratungsstellen erreichen wir
das genaue gegenteil was es braucht sind
dagegen flächendeckende
beratungsangebote zur ganzen vielfalt
menschlicher problemlagen ausreichende
therapie plätze
arbeitsbedingungen in heimen in
krankenhäuser in dem die beschäftigten
zeit für die menschen haben daran dürfen
wir nicht nachlassen zu arbeiten
und ja es bleiben die fälle in denen
jemand ob schwer erkrankt oder nicht
jung oder alt für sich selber
entscheidet das war es jetzt
und dafür auch die selbsttötung die
hilfe anderer menschen erbittet diese
freie entscheidung steht den menschen zu
sie kann bedauert werden
aber sie muss auch respektiert werden
und
dafür müssen wir regelung schaffen die
ärzteschaft hat das mit ihrem
standesrecht bereits getan jetzt sind
wir als gesetzgeber gefordert und müssen
regeln unter welchen umständen die
abgabe eines todbringenden medikamentes
nach dem betäubungsmittelgesetz erlaubt
werden kann
so richtig es ist diesen assistierten
suizid zu ermöglichen so richtig ist es
allerdings einer normalisierung des
suizids entgegenzuwirken
warum eigentlich
weil dann auch die gefahr für die
selbstbestimmung von menschen droht weil
dann der druck steigt dass sich menschen
zu fragen über dinge lohnt sich das noch
falle ich nicht nur zu last was koste
ich und diese fragen verlangen nach der
gegenrede denn niemand in diesem land
soll sich überflüssig fühlen wir wollen
ein gutes land für alle sein und
deswegen friedlich sie gehen sie unseren
weg mit den assistierten suizid zu
ermöglichen ohne ihn zu fördern ich
bitte sie um ihre unterstützung vielen
dank
die strecken das überlegene thomas
rachel cdu csu fraktion thomas rachel
ist in seiner fraktion sprecher für
kirchen und religionsgemeinschaften
bürgerpräsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die menschen werden älter das
eine gute nachricht aber zugleich wächst
bei vielen von ihnen die angst dass sie
im alter oder bei krankheit allein sind
oder leiden viele von ihnen wollen
niemandem zur last fallen
meine damen und herren ist es nicht die
erste debatte die wir zur frage der
sterbehilfe führen und das ist gut so
denn es lenkt unseren blick auf den
menschen und zwar gerade auf den
menschen in seiner verletzlichkeit
vielleicht sogar in seiner
vermeintlichen ausweglosigkeit das macht
mich zuallererst und vor allem demütig
da steht im zentrum unserer bemühungen
der schwerst leidende mensch selbst
soziales handeln ist aus sicht des
christlichen menschenbildes immer
zutiefst zu bedauern und tragisch aus
guten ethischen gründen haben wir uns
2014 zusammen mit den beiden großen
christlichen kirchen gegen die
organisierte und geschäftsmäßige
beihilfe zum suizid ausgesprochen der
suizid seien ethisch wie auch politisch
letztlich nicht vollständig
regulierbarer grenzfall menschlicher
existenz
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat dem
gesetzgeber allerdings aufgefordert die
gesetzlichen neuregelungen für den 1 die
suizid zu schaffen die sorgen vieler
nehme ich sehr ernst denen dieses urteil
zu weit geht besonders hinsichtlich der
schrankenlosen möglichkeit zum
assistierten suizid auch in fällen ohne
schwere oder
lebensbedrohlichen krankheitsverlauf
wir müssen die grund vorgaben des
bundesverfassungsgerichts beachten dabei
gibt es ermessensspielräume die wir als
wertegebundene gesetzgeber ausfüllen
sollten es darf gesellschaftlich nicht
zur normalität werden sich das leben zu
nehmen oder anderen dabei zu helfen
ich glaube dass ein ganz wichtiger punkt
den wir bei der anstehenden gesetzgebung
zwingend berücksichtigen müssen es muss
sichergestellt werden dass menschen
nicht unter einem zusätzlichen druck
geraten jede form der kommerzialisierung
der suizidbeihilfe muss ausgeschlossen
werden genauso wie jede werbung
sehr geehrte damen und herren ein
ermutigendes zeichen im sinne der
ökumene ist die gemeinsame stellungnahme
der katholischen bischöfe und der
evangelischen leitenden geistlichen in
niedersachsen und bremen zur
suizidbeihilfe sie erinnert daran dass
eine gesetzliche regelung für einen
angemessenen umgang mit konkreten
grenzsituationen zwischen leben und tod
letztlich nicht ausreichen sondern jeder
einzelfall multi perspektivisch
betrachtet werden muss
die unterstützung eines suizids sie ist
und bleibt eine gewissensentscheidung in
einer grenz und in einer notsituation
insofern kann auch weder eine person
noch eine institution zur suizidbeihilfe
verpflichtet werden
ob beihilfe zum suizid in grenzen
notsituationen in kirchlichen häusern
geduldet werden solle sei nicht pauschal
zu beantworten
sondern müsse im einzelfall geklärt
werden schreiben zum beispiel die
christlichen kirchen in niedersachsen
neben der selbstbestimmung der
suizidwilligen muss auch die
verantwortung für die angehörigen und
die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
den einrichtungen mit bedacht werden
diese einzel abwägungen wollen und
sollten wir ebenfalls ausreichend raum
geben
unser ganzes bemühen sollte sich aber
vornehmlich auf das eigentliche ziel
konzentrieren nämlich leiden und
schmerzen nach menschen möglichkeit zu
mindern persönliche fürsorge seelsorge
und begleitung zu leisten und die beste
palliativmedizinische und hospizliche
versorgung für alle sicherzustellen
daher brauchen wir als erstes ein gesetz
zum massiven ausbau von niedrig stellen
niedrigschwelligen angeboten zur
suizidprävention
wir brauchen fachlich kompetente und
menschlich zugewandt zugewandte
hospizarbeit und palliativversorgung für
schwer kranke patient innen entscheidend
ist es ein menschenwürdiges leben auch
in der letzten lebensphase sicher zu
stellen denn wir möchten erreichen dass
ein mensch nicht durch die hand eines
anderen sondern an der hand eines
anderen verstört herzlichen dank
thomas rachel hat hier noch mal in
seiner rede darauf hingewiesen dass es
weder zu einer kommerzialisierung der
des assistierten suizids kommen darf
noch zu einer verpflichtung von ärzten
und institutionen diese durchzuführen
till steffen bringen 90 die wahl
gegangen
wir sind heute jeder weil das
bundesverfassungsgericht vor gut zwei
jahren eine richtungsweisende
entscheidung getroffen hat und zwar
das allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht
umfasst eben auch das recht zu
entscheiden wann das leben zu ende sein
soll es erklärte dass im strafgesetzbuch
renommierte verbot der geschäftsmäßigen
förderung der selbsttötung als nichtig
weil es die möglichkeiten einer
assistierte selbsttötung
faktisch weitgehend entleerte
daraus ergibt sich für uns als
gesetzgeber die aufgabe sicherzustellen
dass ein zugang zu freiwillig bereit
gestellter suizidhilfe real gegeben ist
dies ist eine schwierige aufgabe da sie
auf höchst persönliche erfahrungen
ansichten und wertvorstellungen trifft
ich denke jedoch dass die meisten von
uns und wir haben es eben gesehen in
wesentlichen punkten übereinstimmen bei
dem gefühl in eine geschäftsmäßig
betrieben suizidhilfe beschleicht uns
alle ein ungutes gefühl wir haben die
sicherlich nicht unberechtigte sorge
dass die selbsttötung normalisiert wird
und ist daher zu einem anstieg kommt und
ganz besonders besorgt dass uns dass
sich ältere und jüngere menschen auch
von ihrem engsten umfeld zu einer
beendigung ihres lebens gedrängt fühlen
können es stellt sich daher die frage
wie wir diese widersprechenden
interessen am besten zum ausgleich
bringen können ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass der wichtigste baustein
auf diesem weg eine neutrale und
ergebnisoffene beratung ist und dies ist
der weg den unser gesetzentwurf katrin
klar petra sitte hätten den kämpfen
gesprochen denn dieser gesetzentwurf
beschreitet wir wollen dass jeder mensch
der sich mit dem gedanken eine
selbsttötung trägt umfassend informiert
wird über die bedeutung und folgen für
ihn und sein persönliches umfeld
über die voraussetzungen und am
wichtigsten über alternativen jetzt ist
die schaffung einer beratungs
infrastruktur nötig die für alle leicht
zugelegt ist diese beratung die muss
ergebnisoffen erfolgen die beratung soll
aber auch sicherstellen dass betroffenen
etwa bei vorliegen von akuten
psychischen störungen die möglichkeit
zur inanspruchnahme weiterer
hilfsangebot eröffnet wird die beratung
ist die notwendige voraussetzung nach
unserem entwurf um eine ärztliche
verschreibung eines medikaments zur
selbsttötung zu erhalten ein arzt darf
einer person die aus autonomen frei
gebildeten willen ihr leben beenden
möchte dann ein arzneimittel zum zwecke
der selbsttötung verschreiben wobei er
dann auch noch zur umfassende aufklärung
verpflichtet ist dieses verfahren soll
eine geschäftsmäßige suizidhilfe eben
nicht vater sondern überflüssig machen
das ist das ziel gesetzt wird
tatsächlich ist es so dass allein die
möglichkeit suizidhilfe in anspruch zu
nehmen bei nicht wenigen suizidwilligen
den effekt hat von einem solchen
abzusehen ich möchte nicht dass wie es
ein anderer entwurf vorsieht ärzte
letztlich entscheiden ob ein absehbar
nicht mehr veränderlicher sterbewunsch
vorliegt oder nicht auch könnte die
auswahl von ärzten durch angehörige
manipuliert werden und können wir es
ärzten zumuten diese entscheidung zu
treffen ich habe da sorgen zudem
differenziert der entwurf zwischen
sterbewilligen in einer gegenwärtigen
medizinische notlage und anderen
sterbewilligen ich halte diese
abgrenzung für ausgesprochen schwierig
worauf soll abgestellt werden etwa auf
starke schmerzen dass es weitgehend
überholt weil sie sind heutzutage
praktisch alle behandelbar und dann ist
ja die frage was es bei der nicht schwer
kranken oder soll eine staplerhersteller
eine prüfung vornehmen was hat der staat
eigentlich an der stelle zu suchen ich
finde da gehört er nicht hin und
deswegen möchte ich auch nicht dass
menschen dann dieser situation einer
solchen prüfung ausgesetzt sind und der
dritte entwurf der möchte den weg gehen
über strafgesetzbuch das ist nach meiner
ganz festen überzeugung nicht die
richtige stelle für dieses thema die
suizidhilfe hier umfassend zu regeln
enthält ein sehr klare wertung die nach
meiner überzeugung
mit der entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts eben nicht in
einklang steht sie sagt die stört mich
diese entscheidung und ich bin mit der
entscheidung nicht einverstanden und
deswegen gehen wir trotzdem im grunde
den gleichen weg den das
bundesverfassungsgericht verworfen hat
und wir müssen uns dieser aufgabe
stellen dass dieser weg durch das
gericht verbaut worden ist
meine damen und herren das grundgesetz
garantiert ein recht auf leben es
begründet aber keine pflicht zum leben
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat klar
gestellt dass das allgemeine
persönlichkeitsrecht das recht umfasst
zu entscheiden wann das leben zu ende
sein soll an diesem anspruch orientiert
sich unser gesetzentwurf wir möchten
sicherstellen dass der mensch bei aller
notwendigen unterstützung seien
nachhaltig und autonom gebildeten freien
willen nicht mehr leben zu wollen
umsetzen kann dann herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
als nächstes zählt das wort herr kollege
michael kruse fdp fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine
geschätzten kolleginnen und kollegen
zunächst einmal wir führen ja eine
debatte unter aufhebung des
fraktionszwangs für ein thema wie der
sterbehilfe ist das sehr angemessen
dieses verfahren zwingt jeden einzelnen
in diesem raum und jeder einzelne sich
selbst eine eigene haltung zu diesem
thema zu bilden und das ist aus meiner
sicht der entscheidende vorteil der
heutigen debatte und des formats und
deswegen begrüße ich das sehr wir haben
heute viele rechtliche und moralische
aspekte gehört zur korrekten
ausgestaltung der sterbehilfe ich
persönlich habe mich für den antrag der
kollegin katrin hering klar drc steffen
und vielen weiteren otto fricke
entschieden weil ich meine dass es der
antrag ist der der zielstellung die hier
schon oft jetzt rezitiert worden ist am
nächsten kommt nämlich der
freiheit zu einem
selbstbestimmten tod freiheit in allen
lebenslagen aber eben auch freiheit und
selbstbestimmung für das ende des
eigenen lebens und ich möchte nicht all
die argumente wiederholen wir jetzt
schon mehrfach vorgetragen worden sind
sondern von der person erzählen mit der
ich die meisten gespräch über dieses
thema geführt habe das ist meine
großmutter meine großmutter wird am
sonntag 100 jahre alt sie lebt
selbstständig sie lebt allein sie
schreibt mit mir whatsapp kurz vor der
sitzung noch zu diesem thema
und sie ist die person die der ich mich
in diesem thema besonders verpflichtet
fühle weil wir seit vielen jahren
darüber sprechen weil wir über hohes
alter sprechen weil wir darüber sprechen
was es bedeutet wenn der eigene
lebenswille langsam schwindet und
einsatz den sie sehr häufig zu mir
gesagt hat ist ich habe mein leben
gelebt
und wenn ich einmal weggetreten bin dann
helft mir bitte beim sterben und
deswegen weiß ich dass
für
diejenigen die angehörige sind die im
umfeld einer person sind die sich in
diese richtung entscheidet eine hohe
verantwortung besteht dieser hohen
verantwortung versuchen wir mit diesem
vorschlag gerecht zu werden ich habe sie
auch gefragt was sind eigentlich
wären deine wünsche wenn es denn mal so
weit ist sie hat mir gesagt dass sie
sich vor allem wünscht dass es wenig
bürokratie in diesem bereich gibt dass
es einen niedrigschwelligen zugang gibt
dass es keinen missbrauch geben soll und
dass ihr hilfe
zuteil wird wenn der lebenswille listen
wir werden am sonntag ihren hundertsten
geburtstag feiern aber ich weiß auch
dass wenn es einmal so weit sein sollte
dass ihr lebenswille erlischt ich eine
hohe verantwortung dafür trage ihren
willen nachzukommen vielen dank
michael kruse war das nächste reden ist
beatrix von storch stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der afg fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
wenn wir alt und krank sind unsere
geistigen und körperlichen kräfte finden
verliert unser leben nicht sinn und
würde der schriftsteller walter jens war
ein vehementer kämpfer für die aktive
sterbehilfe und später an schwerer
demenz der gesunde walter jens konnte
sich nicht vorstellen dass ein solches
leben für ihn noch lebenswert sein
könnte der an schwerer demenz erkrankte
walter jens wollte dann nicht mehr
sterben sondern leben trotz seiner
patientenverfügung das bezeugten die
menschen die ihn am meisten liebte und
am besten kannten seine frau und sein
sohn und sie ließen ihn leben das urteil
des verfassungsgerichtes den 2017 das
verbot der geschäftsmäßigen
suizidbeihilfe abzuschaffen hat uns auf
eine schiefe bahn gebracht
minderjährige unter 18 dürfen keine
zigaretten kaufen weil
gesundheitsgefährdend aber nach dem
diskussionspapier des bmg seit dem 17 zu
2 1 a 15 jährige sollen einen
selbstbestimmten entschluss zur
selbsttötung treffen können wenn ein
familiengericht die einsicht und
urteilsfähigkeit feststellt wirklich
zigaretten gefährlich aber selbsttötung
möglich
die forderungen nach aktiver sterbehilfe
wird lauter und ich fürchte
wonach suizidbeihilfe
sterbehilfe zur normalität wird
dafür fließen dann auch irgendwann die
grenzen zwischen tötung auf verlangen
und dann auch tötung ohne verlangen die
niederlande sind ein warnendes beispiel
der medizinethiker theo
hat dort festgestellt dass sich seit der
legalisierung der sterbehilfe der
extreme ausnahmefall zum normalfall
entwickelt hat 4 prozent aller
sterbefälle dort sind sterbehilfe ein
drittel so viel
wie corona tote an und mit corona und
zehnmal mehr als verkehrstote 2020 in
den niederlanden 2007 1000 menschen in
deutschland wären das 30.000 in
235 fällen war grund
altersbeschwerden das nachlassen der
sehkraft des gehörs arthritis
gehbeschwerden und den 170 fällen war
der grund demenz meine damen und herren
in den niederlanden ist es zulässig
schwer demenzkranke patienten auch dann
zu töten wenn sie sich verbal heftig non
verbal heftig versuchen dagegen zu
wehren
stärken wir die palliativmedizin schon
oft gesagt helfen wir dass menschen an
der hand eines menschen aber nicht durch
die hand eines menschen
sterben
ich darf zum schluss die deutsche
bischofskonferenz zitieren von 1999 die
schrieb dazu jeder mensch hat seine
würde sein wert und sein lebensrecht von
gott her weil gott allein herr über
leben und tod ist sind menschenwürde und
leben geschützt daran glaube ich vielen
dank
vielen dank gruppe von storch
[Applaus]
das hätten wir auf der ligna scheer
fraktion spd
[Applaus]
sogar der präsident die wir kolleginnen
und kollegen
mich hat doch jetzt noch einmal
aufgeschreckt dieser satz
es darf nicht zur normalität werden denn
herr thomas rachel könnte gerade genannt
hat es darf nicht zur normalität werden
dass man ist vielleicht geneigt zunächst
zu sagen okay normalität und sterben das
wollen wir nicht zusammen denken aber in
normalität steckt auch norm es steckt
auch geregelt hat steckt auch etwas was
wir als selbstverständnis haben in
unserer gesellschaft und der tod und
auch das selbstbestimmte ausscheiden aus
dem leben gehört zur normalität das ist
norm und das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht letztendlich
auch normiert indem es unser grundgesetz
ausgelegt hat in der frage was
selbstbestimmtheit heißt in der frage
des aus dem leben scheiden und hat eben
mit klaren kriterien formuliert wann ein
recht zum selbst tippen starben und
damit natürlich impliziert auch
sterbehilfe zuzubilligen ist nämlich
nämlich wenn es sich um einen autonomen
und einen dauerhaften und ernsthaften
willen das sind die festen kriterien an
denen wir uns orientieren haben und ich
habe große demut und auch ehrfurcht vor
dieser aufgabe dass wir uns hier ein
enorm geben auf dieser basis auf diesen
kriterien neu widmen und zwar insofern
als das ist natürlich immer um ganz
existenzielle individuelle situationen
geht bei denen dieses recht was wir dann
neu zu schaffen hätten zur anwendung
käme
individuelle entscheidungen die wir
nicht zu entscheiden die sind
individuell zu entscheiden wir können
nur den rahmen setzen um diesen recht
dass das verfassungsrecht verbrieft habt
geltung zu verleihen wenn wir jetzt aber
eine weitere runde im bundestag drehen
mit einer gesetzgebung die das
bundesverfassungsgericht für nichtig
erklärt also den boden entzieht zuvor
eine kriminalisierung von
sterbehilfe stattgefunden hat sie war im
gesetz dann hat das eine ist es eine
ausgangs grundlage verdient respekt ab
weil ich anders vermeiden möchte dass
sie erneut eine situation kommen einen
rahmen zu schaffen der wieder
rechtsunsicherheit bringen könnte
vorsorge dass eine nichtigkeit
herauskommt und der kriminalisierung
schaffen könnte und er eben in der
diskussion darüber was denn eigentlich
an legalisierter sterbehilfe existiert
und was nicht bedeuten könnte dass sich
die menschen dem wieder nicht widmen
möchten und alles in die tabu-zone
schieben es darf eben dann doch nicht zu
normen als norm gelten was aber doch
normalität ist es ist normalität wir
können das nicht wegleugnen dass es
menschen gibt die selbstbestimmte
sterben wollen die müssen wir uns
solidarisch mit diesen menschen stellen
diesen umständen müssen wir uns stellen
und insofern ist es konsequent
dass wir wenn wir uns als gesetzgeber
dieser frage widmen
uns in dieser einzelfall orientierte zu
bitten das heißt also auch dass ein
straftatbestand nicht in betracht kommen
kann denn das bundesverfassungsgericht
hat den regelfall definiert der
regelfall ist die erlaubnis wenn wir
jetzt einen straftatbestand mit dem
ausnahmefall der erlaubnis schaffen
würde würden wir dies den den die
aussage des bundesverfassungsgerichts
auf den kopf stellen die rede der
regelfall ist nach dem
bundesverfassungsgericht die erlaubnis
mit sofern es ist wichtig und das ist
aber in dem antrag
kreuth künast dem ich mich auch
angeschlossen habt verbrieft dass man
mit dem
beratungs ein beratungs rahmen
herausfindet welche individuellen fälle
sind bei
welches individuell fans sind mit
autonomen ernsthaft und dauerhaft
angesprochen das müssen wir
identifizieren
ich hoffe wir kommen zu einer guten
lösung in diesem sinne meine zeit ist
abgelaufen fehlen dann
[Applaus]
das wort hat nunmehr stolper freiheit
der kollege hubert hüppe cdu csu
fraktion
herr präsident verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte damen und herren
auch gerade nach dieser rede muss ich
sagen dass es mir noch nie so schwer
gefallen ist eine entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
zu akzeptieren wie diese die dort
gefallen ist und ich will sie begründen
denn es zwingt mich an einer regelung
mitzuwirken die ich von meinem gewissen
her grundsätzlich eigentlich nicht nur
eigentlich ablehnen muss
und das ist nicht deswegen weil ich
nicht verstehen kann wenn menschen die
ich das leben nehmen worden ich schließe
das übrigens für mich auch nicht aus ob
ich nie in einer solchen situation
kommen könnte aber ich möchte einfach
nicht dass eine regelung kommt die dass
die beihilfe zur selbsttötung sozusagen
als therapeutische alternative sieht das
möchte ich verhindern und meine damen
und herren die meisten menschen die sich
selbst töten sind depressiv alt oder
behindert chronisch krank
pflegebedürftig verwitwet arbeitslos
oder einsam und die suizidforschung
weist darauf hin dass hinter vier und
suizidversuchen eine psychische
erkrankung oder sozialer probleme stehen
und die wenigsten menschen die nach
einem suizidversuch professionelle hilfe
erhalten machen jemand wieder einen
druck sieht versucht und wir beobachten
dass die debatte um die beihilfe zur
selbsttötung verschärft wurde zeit
unsere gesellschaft älter wird und wir
führen sie auch auf dem hintergrund dass
wir überall über pflegenotstand
pflegende und fehlende hilfe
insbesondere in einrichtungen reden
meine damen und herren pflegende vor
menschen die gepflegt werden müssten in
einrichtung deren entscheidung kann auch
sehr wohl beeinflusst werden dadurch wie
die umstände in einer einrichtung sind
und wenn s
und wenn es ein gesetzlich garantiert
das recht auf assistierten suizid gibt
dann ist auch klar dass nicht mehr das
schicksal dafür verantwortlich ist wenn
ich aus kranke auto oder
pflegebedürftiger mensch die
gesellschaft insbesondere auch meine
verwandten belastet sondern ich selber
bin es der sie belastung und denn wenn
assistierter suizid einmal
gesellschaftlich akzeptiert wird
dann trage ich schließlich die
verantwortung dafür dass ich weiterleben
und die ressourcen der allgemeinheit in
anspruch nehmen will und was
wahrscheinlich viel entscheidender ist
mein angehörigen zur last falle selbst
wenn das objektiv nicht stimmt reicht
allein schon das empfinden anderen zur
last zu fallen um mich um sich moralisch
verpflichtet zu fühlen sich für den
suizid zu entscheiden und das ist meine
damen und herren ist keine spekulation
sondern die erfahrung aus ländern in
denen schon länger die der ärztlich
assistierter suizid legal praktiziert
wird das bundesverfassungsgericht wenn
man sich mal das urteil wird durch liest
sagt selber dass in oregon wo wir eine
solche regelung schon seit über 20
jahren haben 54 prozent derer die sich
mit dem ärztlichen assistenz das leben
genommen haben angegeben haben dass sie
sorge haben ihrer familie freunden
pflegenden zu last zu fallen so das so
sagt es zumindest der offizielle
jahresbericht in oregon von 2021
und das war dem bundesverfassungsgericht
bekannt und es trifft eben die sozial
schwachen in oregon warnt 80 prozent der
assistierten suiziden menschen die sich
haben
die sich getötet haben
waren menschen die nur die mindest
krankenversorgung bekamen wie medicaid
und medicare
2008 eingeführt wurde waren es unter
zehn prozent das zeigt auch meine damen
und herren den trend und während
während wir diese diskussion führen
müssen wir einfach auch wissen dass
dieser gesellschaftliche druck natürlich
auch auf andere möglicherweise
übergreift wir haben die diskussion
gehabt über demenzielle menschen was ist
eigentlich mit menschen mit behinderung
die seit ihrer geburt nie als
entwicklungsfähig haben die auch ein
recht auf selbsttötung wie wird das
umgesetzt und wie sieht es denn wirklich
aus werden wir diese hauchdünne
unterscheidung wirklich beibehalten
können zwischen töten auf verlangen
und
der beihilfe zur selbsttötung wie will
ich eigentlich jeden mann mehr erklären
meine damen und herren
dass er die wirklich jemand mehr
erklären dass er zwar das recht auf
seine selbsttötung hat aber wenn er
nicht in der lage ist das glas zu nehmen
ihm kein anderer dieses glas nehmen kann
und deswegen zum schluss meine damen und
herren hoffe ich wenigstens dass wir zu
einer regelung kommt die die
suizidprävention stärkt und die die
schwachen vor vermeintlichen druck
hubert hüppe hat hier auch nochmal seine
bedenken formuliert unter anderem auch
was eine solche regelung für menschen
mit behinderungen bedeuten würde
engagiert sich schon seit langem in der
behindertenpolitischen arbeit
nochmal einmal daran erinnern fast am
ende dieser debatte dass wir uns glaube
ich darüber einig sind dass jeder der
entwürfe die wir heute diskutieren
besser ist als der aktuelle
rechtszustand ihr nämlich sehr
ungeregelt ist was viele einzelfragen
angeht und ich glaube wir sind uns auch
einig darüber an dieser debatte dass am
ende dieses gesetzgeberischen prozesses
das klare votum dieses hauses steht ja
die autonome
selbsttötung mit assistenz ist zulässig
und sie ist dein recht aber wir müssen
genauso klar die botschaft dagegen
stellen und mit
darzustellen kein leben ist eine last in
dieser gesellschaft menschliches leben
ist immer ein wert an sich und das
ändert sich nicht durch alter und
gebrechlichkeit das ändert sich nicht
durch behinderung das ändert sich nicht
durch eine suchtproblematik oder die
vielen anderen dinge die jeden für sich
selbst in zweifel bringen können ob man
eigentlich in einer situation ist aus
der mann noch wieder herausfindet oder
ob man nicht tatsächlich sich für andere
zu einer schwierigkeit ausweitet und das
ist eine gemeinsame aufgabe die wir in
diesem gesetzentwurf nicht werden lösen
können nämlich diesen staat so weiter
auszubauen dass wir stärker zu einer
integrativen inklusiven gesellschaft
kommen die menschen in solchen
situationen abholt und die ihnen klar
signalisiert du bist uns wertvoll denn
jedes menschliche leben ist wertvoll und
es ist keine wertung durch andere
zugänglich niemals in diesem land wieder
und an dieser stelle ist die
zivilisatorische decke manchmal dünn die
diskussion um pränataldiagnostik um
viele andere dinge haben uns das immer
wieder gezeigt und deswegen ist es
unsere gemeinsame aufgabe zu ermöglichen
was das verfassungsgericht uns
aufgegeben hat aber auch zusagen
menschliches leben ist in deutschland im
jahr 2022 immer wertvoll und wir werden
alles tun sich dabei zu unterstützen
erst zu erhalten das ist unsere aufgabe
dabei haben wir eine gemeinsame ich
hoffe daran arbeiten wir auch zusammen
vielen dank
ich trete nicht die kollegin kerstin
griese spd fritz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber
kolleginnen kollegen daran kann ich sehr
gut angst nutzen denn auch ich sage als
erstes in dieser debatte steht im
mittelpunkt der mensch jeder mensch die
würde jedes menschen und die würde jedes
menschen ist gleich viel wert unabhängig
davon ob er alt krank leiden behindert
ist und der respekt vor der würde des
menschen vor der würde des lebens leitet
mich in dieser debatte
dabei geht es um zwei dinge erstens um
die selbstbestimmung und den freien
willen und es geht und das gehört
zusammen um ein schutzkonzept dass diese
selbstbestimmung gesichert gerade der
schutz von wohlhabenden gruppen von
menschen die in notsituationen sind in
leidenden situationen ist gerade dieser
schutz ist wichtig jedes leben hat die
gleiche würde und niemand hat darüber zu
urteilen ob eines weniger oder mehr
lebenswert wäre
und deshalb unterstütze ich den
gesetzentwurf von lars castellucci und
anderen denn wir wollen wie das
bundesverfassungsgericht es vorgibt
assistierten suizid nach engen regeln
ermöglichen aber wir wollen ihn doch
nicht fördern wir wollen ihnen doch
nicht bewerben wir finden ihn doch nicht
gut sondern wir wollen doch dann wenn
menschen das wollen nach bestimmten
regeln nach zweimaligen arzt gesprächen
nach zeit dazwischen zum nachdenken
ermöglichen aber ihnen doch nicht
fördern sondern wir wollen menschen
unterstützen wenn sie leben wollen
und selbst beim bundesverfassungsgericht
bei dem urteil dabei und das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat
selbstverständlich klar ob das mittel
des strafrechts dafür für möglich
gehalten dass hat es nicht
ausgeschlossen dass kann gegen so
und deshalb jahr wir wollen mit diesem
gesetz sterbehilfe vereine regulieren
wir wollen nicht das was jetzt ist dass
sie unbegrenzt machen können was sie
wollen sondern wir wollen regeln
schaffen nach denen assistierte suizid
mögliche
und selbstbestimmung kommt nicht ohne
den schutz der schwachen funktionieren
die achtung vor dem leben gebietet dass
und ich will dass menschen in
pflegeheimen und jeder der das einmal
erlebt hat weiß wie das ist ich will
dass menschen nichts unternehmen druck
druck geraten ihr leben zu beenden weil
dieser druck da ist weil er assistierte
suizid doch ein so vermeintlich einfache
gute schmerzfreie schnelle lösung wäre
ich will dass sie in diesen situationen
allen schutz und alle hilfe bekommen und
selbstverständlich ist sterbehilfe in
deutschland möglich deshalb ist in der
tat der titel der debatte falsch es geht
hier um den assistierten suizid sterben
hilfe beim sterben ist in deutschland
möglich von der palliativen sedierung
über verschiedene formen von abbruch von
behandlungen alles was ein patient
verfügung steht ist natürlich möglich
damit menschen frei und selbstbestimmt
zu leben und sterben können wie sie
wollen hilfe beim sterben ist möglich
aber es geht eben darum wie wir die
hilfe zum sterben so begrenzt wie
möglich regeln
ich bräuchte diesem druck wenn der
assistierte suizid ein normalfall wäre
und ich will nicht dass wir bundesweit
suizid beratungsstellen haben die den
assistierten suizid befördern
stattdessen brauchen wir bundesweit
sowie die prävention wir brauchen
unterstützung für menschen in diesen
situationen
und kollegin konnte hat es schon gesagt
erwiesenermaßen dazu gibt es wirklich
viele forschungstaucher castellucci
gesagt ist der suizid wunsch ein
volatiler und der satz ich will nicht
mehr leben bedeutet so oft ich will so
nicht leben und gerade dann kann man so
viel hilfe anbieten und ich danke allen
die sich im hospiz verein engagieren in
der palliativmedizin engagieren davon
brauchen wir noch viel mehr um hilfe
begleitung unterstützung niemand muss
qualvoll sterben und vor allem sollen
niemand alleine sterben müssen
und ich will auch deutlich sagen gar
keine regelung ist keine lösung gar
keine regelung bürger
wurde denn stabil ist vor allem wie dem
von herrn kusch ads tür und tor weiter
öffnen das haben wir jetzt diese
situation das halte ich für ethisch
nicht tragbar ich finde wir müssen uns
dieser schwierigen aufgabe stellen als
gesetzgeber dafür regeln zu finden und
auch ein gesellschaftliches klima zu
schaffen dass die würde des menschen in
den mittelpunkt stellt dass die
unterstützung für menschen gerade in
notsituationen in den mittelpunkt stellt
und deshalb haben wir einen
gesetzentwurf entwickelt der den
assistierten suizid nach vorgaben des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes zwar möglich
macht der dafür aber eben ärztliche
beratung vorsieht einen zeitlichen
abstand und wir haben es verbunden mit
einem antrag der die suizidprävention in
deutschland verbessert wir haben
außerdem ausdrücklich gesagt für unter
18 jährige geht es nicht wir reden hier
darüber wie wir leben wie wir sterben
und das hat viel damit zu tun welches
bild wir von der gesellschaft haben
gerade da zeigt es sich wie wir die
würde jedes einzelnen wahrnehmen ich
freue mich auf gute beratung und hoffe
auf ein gutes gemeinschaftliches
ergebnis
womit der assistierte suizid darf nicht
zum normalfall werden diese befürchtung
wurde hier schon häufiger in dieser
orientierungs debatte genannt so auch
von kerstin krise die hier auch nochmal
davor gewarnt hat erich irlstorfer
spricht jetzt für die unionsfraktion
auch er sitzt sonst im
gesundheitsausschuss
werte herr präsident geschätzte
kolleginnen und kollegen
der tod gehört zum leben
und jedes leben hat einen wert
doch der
frieden wohlstand und luxus
haben wir dieses ungeliebte thema
sterben und tod
aus der gesellschaftlichen mitte an den
rand unseres denkens und handelns
irgendwie verdammt
es ist eher die ausnahme dass die
letzten stunden und minuten
und der gewohnten häuslichkeit
erlebt werden dürfen weil wir gott sei
dank sage ich
senioreneinrichtungen haben
krankenhäuser und eine äusserst fähige
hospiz infrastruktur
und das hilft uns als angehörige
und das hilft uns dabei diese schwersten
stunden durchzustehen und deshalb an
dieser stelle heute auch mal ein
herzliches vergelt's gott an alle die
hier in den dienst am menschen leisten
diese orientierungs debatte
ist wichtig und es gibt hier die gruppe
um kollegen usinger
sie erarbeitet hat dass man mit
fachpersonal aus psychiatrie
menschen die den wunsch des sterbens in
sich tragen über alternativen
informieren sollen
und sie sagt aber auch dass assistiert
das so ist soll ermöglicht werden darf
aber nicht gefördert werden 90 prozent
der fälle entstehen durch und in
ausnahmesituationen
auch das müssen wir uns sagen hatten
das thema missbrauch soll natürlich
geahndet und bestraft werden das ist
klar darüber sind wir uns eigentlich
dass kinder und jugendliche
sind von dass sterbehilfe hier
ausgeschlossen
und ich lege einen besonderen wert
darauf dass wir hier gemeinsam darauf
bauen sollen dass die palliativmedizin
und die hospizbewegung nicht nur
grandios leistet sondern dass sie hier
auch ein schlüssel zum besseren lebens
zeigen und deshalb ist es wichtig dass
wir die hand reichen zu hilfe und in
meinen augen nicht
natürlich muss kein mensch schmerzen
ertragen es sind der medizin ist soweit
und können wirklich auch helfen was
sollen wir tun
und dieses private erlebnis beim sterben
meinen vater das war wirklich eine
erleben was mich sehr geprägt hat wie er
sagte wer ordentlich gelebt hat war
offentlich sterben
ich habe das interpretieren lassen der
wunsch war geheim zu sterben in seine
umwelt und ich glaube auch dass es die
chance ist nach die kernaufgabe ist von
familie aber auch von kirchen und
glaubensgemeinschaften
hier das thema seelsorge auch in den
mittelpunkt zu stehen und
mich leitet immer noch
dieser satz
erinnern höfner von sich gegeben hat
also sagte der mensch stirbt nicht an
einer krankheit sondern dann wenn dort
ein leben vollendet hat herzlichen dank
erich irlstorfer war das hier mit sehr
persönlichen
beweggründen wie er auf die debatte
schaut und damit kommen wir zum letzten
redner in dieser orientierungs debatte
das ist herbert und wollmann spd
fraktion und auch
als letzte reden da ist es natürlich
nicht so leicht oder als letzter arena
hier noch neuigkeiten
zu verbreiten aber ich versuche es am
ende meiner rede dann doch wir wissen
dass 2020 im februar das
bundesverfassungsgericht den paragrafen
217 für nichtig erklärt hat und das mit
einer gesetzesvorlage von oder
begründung von 115 seiten
das gericht hat eindeutig klar gemacht
dass die autonomie des einzelnen
menschen in befähigt über sein leben und
seinen tod selbst zu bestimmen das heißt
die freiheit sich das leben zu nehmen
umfasst auch die freiheit die hilfe
dritter in anspruch zu nehmen rein
formal ist die suizidabsichten nicht nur
zu dulden sondern auf humane weise sogar
zu ermöglichen die sozis absicht ist
darüber hinaus dauert dieses gesetzes
weder zu begründen noch zu rechtfertigen
dabei sind weder alter noch
krankheit einer voraussetzung für die
anspruch nahm also zieht hilfe ich
betone um erklärt das natürlich niemand
verpflichtet werden kann so zierte wird
zu leisten
warum kommen wir überhaupt zusammen wenn
die fakten so eindeutig sind
ist der sozialhilfe damit jede
beschränkung genommen worden
da muss ich frau gunners widersprechen
nein wir müssen zusammenkommen das
gericht hat den gesetzgeber ausdrücklich
zu einer detaillierten regulierung dazu
zitierte beauftragt dabei haben höchste
priorität der nachweis der
freiverantwortlich
die wohl erwogen haid und die
nachhaltigkeit des entschlusses der
suizidwilligen
außerdem das wurde auch schon mehrmals
betont dachte er suizid wunsch nicht auf
druck von außen kommen daher kommt der
suizidprävention natürlich mehr denn je
eine enorme bedeutung zu
soziale notsituationen akute
belastungsstörung behandelbare
krankheiten insbesondere aus dem bereich
der psychiatrie müssen sicher
ausgeschlossen sein bzw behandelt werden
um einen suizid zu verhindern
allein diese beispiele zeigen dass es
einen wohlrabe personenkreis gibt der
vor dem entschluß sich das leben zu
nehmen unbedingt geschützt werden muss
wer meine rede verfolgt hat wird
aufgefallen sein dass ich das wort
sterbehilfe bis jetzt nicht in den mund
genommen habe der titel und das wurde
auch schon gesagt orientierungs debatte
zur sterbehilfe ist im grunde völlig
falsch wir reden hier
wir reden ja suizidhilfe
suizidhilfe von sterbehilfe sind
verschiedene themenkreise so ehrenwert
jeder hundertste geburtstag ist ich
bewundere das aber das ist nicht der
kern dessen was wir heute oder demnächst
besprechen und beschließen müssen das
muss ich ganz klar so sagen seit jeher
leisten fachkräfte die sich mit der
medizin am lebensende beruflich
beschäftigen sterbehilfe
auch mehr muss ich allerdings ehrlich
sagen würden die fundamentalen
unterschiede zur sterbehilfe und
suizidbeihilfe erst im laufe der zeit
klar
und damit wurde mir bewusst dass es eine
sehr sind übrigen regelwerkes bedarf um
missbrauch zu verhindern
lassen sie mich zum schluss noch zwei
ganz wesentliche aspekte eingehen
mir ist überhaupt nicht klar wie die
suizidhilfe bei nicht volljährigen zu
regeln ist ich kenne auch keine
positionspapiere die für eine
gesetzesvorlage tauglich wären um kinder
und jugendliche ausreichend zu würdigen
ich möchte darauf hinweisen es gab vor
kurzem mit dem deutschen ethikrat dazu
eine ein online format und gras ist
dieses thema wurde sehr ausführlich
diskutiert das ist nicht abschließend zu
beurteilen
wir können uns diesen hochsensiblen
problem nicht verschließen denn laut
verfassungsgericht und das muss ich
betonen lauf verfassungsrecht gilt das
urteil in jeder phase der menschlichen
existenz wiederhole in jeder phase der
menschlichen existenz was immer auch das
zu bedeuten hat die stellungnahme des
deutschen ethikrates ist erst im
september zu erwarten das haben sie uns
vorher mittwoch mitgeteilt
das heißt wir sollten nicht vorschnell
jetzt dinge versuchen umzusetzen die in
der vorigen legislaturperiode
versäumt worden danke
vielen dank herr villiger weil man damit
schließlich die aussprache und gebe zu
weit war also hier diese orientierungs
debatte in der die abgeordneten
unabhängig von ihrer parteizugehörigkeit
ihrer meinung ihre position zu diesem
doch sehr schwierigen thema äußern
konnten das war hat man auch gemerkt es
war eine nicht polemisch geführte
nachdenkliche debatte hier denn die
abwägung zwischen dem schutz des lebens
und das selbstbestimmungsrecht das ist
nicht leicht wie man das in ein gesetz
befassen kann es gibt bisher drei
gesetzentwürfe die jetzt noch weiter
ausgearbeitet werden können eventuell
kommen auch noch neue gesetzentwürfe
dazu im sommer soll es eine erste lesung
dann hier im parlament zu
gesetzentwürfen geben und im herbst zu
ist momentan der plan soll dann
abschließend darüber abgestimmt werden
in der letzten legislaturperiode hat das
nicht geklappt eine einigung zu finden
nun geht es in dieser legislatur
natürlich noch etwas mehr